hey all Peter Kumble feed roses here to
discuss evil ryu in Ultra Street Fighter
4 evil Ryu is known for big burst damage
but outside of that his tools were a tad
limited let's look at his changes to see
if this issue was finally addressed Eva
you players told us that evil Ryu has
decent damage output but as though life
resulted in them losing way before they
could get their offense started to
address that we've increased his total
life by 50 which is definitely help in
the long run evil Ryu starting combo was
decent however due to and only coming
out after his close standing middle
punch ifs utility was rather limited to
increase its overall utility the target
combo can now be performed from further
out allowing for new pressure strings
and combo opportunity the primary
purpose of evil reuse forward and middle
kick was to go over low attacks and
allow him a way to get in from further
out unfortunately some characters
thought too low to get hit by it
resulting in this move being less
effective than it should have been to
ensure that this attack worked as
intended the hip box around evil reuse
foot has been increased quite
dramatically even reuse sure you can
attack into focus - counsel forward was
a great low-risk high-reward method
players with used to swing a match back
into their favor without really worrying
about possibly repercussions this has
since been changed at Ultra Street
Fighter 4 with the reduction on the
advantage evil receives after focus
cancelling an uppercut if done
incorrectly evil Ryu now faces the
potential to be punished after a forward
- so be more cautious than using this
Hebrew Ryu was a fairly good character
in AE 2012 and only needed of new tweaks
to become that much more solid
with the improvements to the vitality
and key normal evil Ryu will definitely
become a force to be reckoned with this
time around
you